I'm mark Hamlet I'm provost here at
Carnegie Mellon and it's a delight to
welcome you to I think this is our
fourth innovators forum over the past
two or three years and these are special
occasions for us here at Carnegie Mellon
where we get the opportunity to get to
talk to and hear from some of the most
creative entrepreneurs of our time and
today we're very very privileged to have
Vinod Khosla who is an extraordinarily
accomplished creative entrepreneur and a
company creator and venture capitalists
and person impacting the world in
extraordinary ways I know you know a lot
about the nodes accomplishments but let
me just remind you that among the many
is he's a alum from Carnegie Mellon
having received a master's in biomedical
engineering after his act coming to the
u.s. from iit delhi i believe and a
founder of daisy systems and then
founding CEO of Sun Microsystems which
the pioneering work in all that Sun did
in open systems and RISC processors and
and alike one of our other alums andy
bechtolsheim and a friend of a node has
said of him the note is a visionary who
likes to make big bets on ideas that can
really change the world and we are
delighted that he's with us I'm going to
ask him to
come up here to the stage and in fact
even Odin come on up and
thank you very much for being with us
I'm great to be here I'm going to ask a
few questions just to get the ball
rolling but we will be sure to have time
for you to be part of this discussion as
well because the format is intentionally
informal we want this to be a back and
forth and but note has indicated that
he's open for all questions that this is
a to be an open an interesting
discussion don't be polite be a little
plight so what I thought I would start
you know somebody mentioned or read
something in the context of the way you
go about in terms of picking people and
into in terms of picking projects and
businesses and that you have liked to
say that you invest in people as much as
the initial clever business idea how do
you evaluate entrepreneurs who come to
you and want to get your support um let
me you know it's it's funny people laugh
and I say don't be polite but I actually
mean it it's an essential quality of
entrepreneurs to to challenge things
maybe even disrespect authority you know
when my kids were five I sort of
probably was the main guy who threw food
at them because they were too
well-behaved I had the reverse problem
my kids would like a little too
well-behaved so my daughter just had a
25th birthday and we were at a party at
rest at a restaurant with all her
friends and she was telling me over the
weekend that my friends think you're
really cool because I actually threw
some food at some of her friends and
these are 25 year olds and they thought
it was cool I think shaking things up is
an essential part of entrepreneurship in
sort
of all most challenging disrespecting
Authority not not being too confirming
our essential parts of entrepreneurship
the other piece that I find is religions
really important religion in whatever
you want to do most people don't know
this but this is an interesting fact
that most of you have probably heard of
the god gene that makes people more
religious turns out that applies not
only to religions like Christianity it
applies equally to religion about
entrepreneurship this book called on
being certain when you are wrong why do
you have such strong beliefs about being
certain when you're wrong the gene is
common between really religious people
who believe in their religion
entrepreneurs who believe in their
business plan it's the same gene written
by a neuro scientist I forget his name
really good book so passionate about
what you want to do is an essential part
to me about being a good entrepreneur
being a little bit of a troll a little
bit of a disrespect I have a lot of
disrespect for authority and
conventional wisdom and by the way for
expert opinion we I'd love to talk about
expert opinion you didn't ask me but
what do you think about expert opinion
good question turns out one of the
reasons to be disrespectful for
authority and conventional wisdom is
exported doesn't isn't very good first
I'll give you anecdotal evidence Martin
Luther King said human salvation lies in
the hands of the socially maladjusted
George Bernard Shaw said
something similar he said I am trying to
remember the exact quote that but he'll
come to me but this most rigorous study
of expert opinion and there's obviously
lots of knowledgeable professors who
have expert opinions in their domains
this is a bad thing to say at a place
like Syria but Professor tetlock at UC
Berkeley formally studied expert opinion
and he took 28,000 forecasts and across
a number of domains from reading brain
imaging scans to what will happen in
China or what will happen to the Soviet
Union to how will GDP growth happen what
will it be next quarter and he found
across 28,000 forecasts a 20-year study
about 250 experts followed closely that
the rough accuracy was the same as
dart-throwing monkeys for those of you
statistically inclined read his book
called expert political judgment those
of you want just a fun sunday read the
same data is captured in a book called
future Babel and future Babel is exactly
the essence of entrepreneurship if what
expert opinion is is Babel which I truly
believe and calm ox said when the Train
of history hits a curve the
intellectuals fall off see a lot of
intellectuals among the experts in that
universities not a fan of Karl Marx but
true fan of capitalism but I think
there's real truth so that's my view of
expert opinion if we can be so wrong and
take a rigorous i'll give you my
favorite example a rigorous thing like
medical studies on whether you should
take lipitor or Staten if you have if
you want to lower your cholesterol
and does it impact heart disease
professor iron it is who's that the
Stanford School of Medicine I followed
him for years when he was in Greece made
the following statement he's the world's
expert on medical studies so he studies
medical studies he said any given study
that is accepted today is more likely to
be wrong than right now think about that
all of medicine is based on these
studies and most expert opinion is wrong
you know go to your family doctor if you
have little kids and they have very high
temperature ask them if you should what
you should do what the first thing they
say take some tylenol aspirin reduce the
fever turns out that piece of expert
opinion has never been tested except
once and the one time it was tested was
tested in I ICU unit of the hospital at
University of Miami among eighty some
patients half of them controls and the
death rate among kids in the ICU where
they were doing the practice of reducing
fever was so high they discontinued the
study on ethical grounds so a simple
fact like doctors telling you reduce the
temperature can be wrong and that's why
dr. ayan it is and so back full circle
if you're not to know you want
innovation ignore everything you know
about what's expected to happen sounds
like good advice I guess I know you have
had such a passion and commitment and
engagement in energy and environment and
I want to kind of raise one or two
questions to take take advantage of all
all that you've done in your thinking in
the area you know there's a particularly
in this area in western Pennsylvania
with shale gas and so forth and the
predictions by some experts on the
possibility
of the u.s. becoming energy sufficient
or whatever I guess my question is
whether or not that notion of us energy
sufficiency is even the right way to
think about energy policy and what you
think lies ahead maybe a little bit
unfair because we're sort of in the
midst of that shale area but so let me
go back to this issue of expert opinion
I'm there is clearly these experts who
have opinions but if you go back to 2008
not very long ago five years ago summer
of two thousand eight you asked any
expert five years ago would say there's
going to be a shortage of natural gas in
the United States the one the largest
areas of investment in natural gas was
building LNG terminals to import the
actual ganas five years ago and so in a
typical lng project it takes somewhere
between seven to ten years to build it
opinion can change you in five years
none of those experts are now
accountable mm-hmm but they wrote their
papers moved on the but they were
dramatically wrong in predicting natural
gas trajectory I contend it it's the
same is true going forward five years
from now if one technology showed up
conversion of natural gas to liquid
fuels one little technology all those
assumptions would be wrong again right
so the point is technology changes cause
economic disruption and you can do what
the experts do is what Karl Marx said
extrapolate the past right and when that
train of history hits a curve there's a
change in technology all those
assumptions are wrong so look I can be a
better forecasting expert
with about 75 to 80 percent accuracy in
most places by saying the weather
tomorrow is going to be the same as the
weather today so extrapolating the past
works the question is opinions only
matter if they change what a simplistic
model can do and there's been enough
studies to say most expert opinion can
be improved upon by building the sim
most simplistic of models like in
weather forecasting so you can
extrapolate the past shale gas is an
example or what I like to say is you can
invent the future you want and that's
what in a waiter's do forget what others
believe I'm going to change the planet
with some innovation and change the
course so if you came up with one little
technology to take natural gas and turn
it into liquid fuels interchangeable
with oil suddenly natural gas everywhere
in the world would be priced like Oilers
and be an international commodity and
you wouldn't be this is a u.s. solution
and that's a solution in Europe or
Russia you'd say it's a international
commodity I think it's very likely to
happen in fact we have one company doing
just that take the abundant shale gas
and converted into liquid fuels to year
three years ago they're working on
converting biomass into liquid fuels and
they said lot easier and a lot cheaper
to take natural gas and converted liquid
fuels and suddenly five years from now
the experts will be saying something
else I'll make a general comment about
this used to be in a lot of CMU people
are engineers in engineers in
engineering we were taught to optimize
something optimize costs optimize
performance more throughput more
transactions per second in a database
lower cost engines more efficient
engines I actually think what needs to
be done where education needs to change
for engineers and scientists is too
learn to optimize for agility and
adaptability the world is changing
faster and faster at some point you say
there's no way to predict what the world
will do and I always assume I have no
way of predicting where the world will
go or just going to be very adaptable
and agile which brings me to this
related topic I hate titles like energy
visionary I think the only thing I'm
visionary about is knowing I don't have
a clue I think we're where other people
make mistakes is to pretend they know
where we're going but in almost every
area most of the really interesting
things happen because you you discover
it you invent it you make it happen not
because it was predicted and so the
notion of vision is really a wrong
notion I like to say I screw up more
often and faster than most people I fail
more than most people and I phenomena
say my willingness to fail is the only
thing that gives me an ability to
succeed think about it unless I was
willing to fail I wouldn't take any
risks then I'd be in the realm of
extrapolate the past do what experts
tell you what what's happening next my
willingness to try high risk things is
what gives me the ability to unusual
things because I'm trying them you know
it's sort of called you can fail and try
or fail to try right pic and most people
fail to try instead of trying and
failing I like trying and failing I like
to say I don't mind failing in fact
people criticize me for saying I'll
invest in projects that have a ninety
percent chance of failure but use the
probability of failure
so much that the consequences of success
are inconsequential you can take a much
more in the Nassim Taleb camp as a
financial investor by an option on
something that's at large impact and
small costs to failing try lots of
little things small cost to failing
high-upside when you succeed that's not
about vision it's about premature
confidence maybe arrogance it's about
the things that are key to innovation
and innovators so we're in a framework
because you set forth where it's very
hard to predict what's going to come to
be the willingness to take risks and to
explore but on the other hand if you're
say President Obama or if you're at a
national policy level the policies that
go into place something has to sort of
be chosen I know that you have had many
opportunities on the national stage I
recall you were here a couple years ago
with President Obama in fact discussing
some of these issues included including
energy issues in terms of national
policy takes something like like a
carbon tax for instance there you don't
know what it's going to lead
specifically but but but you are needing
to set a policy and moreover you
probably want to make that policy
whatever it is as clear and its precise
so people sort of sort of have a sense
of what of what they're dealing with
what would your thoughts be with regard
either specifically to something like a
carbon tax or cap and trade as the case
may be or other areas of that let me
answer that question more generally
about 18 months ago I was invited to
speak to then by the Secretary of the
Navy to talk to the Navy energy is a
major global issue energy is a major
driver off the Navy and what they can
can't do you in the middle of the ocean
and can't get your fuel your
you got a problem so they asked me
there's a hundred roughly 150 Admirals
in the Navy they were having a meeting
planning for Navy 2040 mm-hmm and they
asked me to open this sort of conference
they were having for just the Admirals
now think about the problem you have to
plan the Navy you can't build aircraft
carrier in less than 15 years you if you
have research it's even longer to first
design new capability like for the new
Joint Strike Force fighter so what do
you do huh and but I started by asking
this was 2011 I said in the year 2000
what was the Navy's mission top three
missions I turned out China didn't
figure in the mission we forget the
China was not politically considered
important Japan was the other economic
powerhouse and not that long ago and I
said if your mission has changed but
there was no 911 there was no al Qaeda
there was a very different world for the
Navy and I said if you didn't know what
your mission was in 2004 what would be
important in 2011-2012 how can you plan
20 40 and they now have a new set of
missions I call that the pretense of
knowing you pretend you know something
that you known no you're much so the
question was then after I gave my talk
about this baloney about planning the
Navy for 20 41 dead medals ask me so
what should we do my answer was if you
know you don't know you do different
things than pretending here's the three
scenarios you have to plan for and their
response was the world's changing really
rapidly
instead of three scenarios let's plan
the Navy for five scenarios and I said
if you did 15 you still wouldn't predict
Osama bin Laden and one guy causing that
much change in global politics and if
you suddenly discovered shale gas and
energy wasn't a big issue suddenly your
mission changes it's no longer
protecting the sea lions by the way just
protecting the oil lanes in the last 25
30 years we've spent seven trillion
dollars which is really a subsidy to the
oil industry because we're doing their
transportation insurance for them so
when you think about it this way you
engineer these systems to be adaptive
and agile which is a very different cast
than taking any mission whether it's one
or five and optimizing for them and Don
Rumsfeld after fighting the Iraq war
essentially said we no longer need
traditional defense which upset a lot of
Defense people we need agility for the
unknown unknown I think that was his
famous line I think what are you
building an engineering system a
computer system I mean imagine computing
workloads have changed I know the head
of the computer science departments here
workloads have changed so dramatically
Big Data Hadoop all that not one piece
of architectural change has happened to
accommodate those and I can't find a
place during computer architecture for
these new loads and so somebody asked me
so what would you do and they sort of
said here's the new architecture I said
no wrong approach that's new
architecture if you assume Hadoop is
your big data computing environment and
big data revolves around her do but
almost certainly in five years nobody
will be talking about Hadoop as a big
data computing environment let's build
an adaptable system I said why don't we
instrument the device to reconfigure
some things every minute some things
every our some things every day and some
things once a month huh now nobody's
doing that in computer science that I
know of that I've been able to find so
adaptability and agility in the face of
rate of change become the most important
things to optimize for make sense I want
to take advantage of being the moderator
to ask one more question but then I'm
going to also hope they'll be to keep
hogging all the questions here and turn
it over to some all the guy talks too
long no no no no no I but I do want to
get one one other one in so we're very
excited we are opening up a major energy
institute thus God Institute I know
you've been involved with some of the
discussions that we've had the
opportunity to have as we think through
in fact we're even more pleased we
receive not only the generous gift from
from the Scots but 30 million dollars
just this past week we were able to
announce in the Richard King mellon
Foundation I know that one of the things
that we would say that we are
particularly focused on as an area where
we think we can bring something to the
debates and policies on energy and an
environment has to do a sort of systems
of systems sort of systems analysis but
probably taking one step up and I know
you know a lot about what we sort of
have as a backbone in that in that
regard but would you have any advice for
us it's kind of a selfish CMU central
question but do you have any advice for
us on how you think we should prioritize
you know we're an academic setting this
new energy Institute's not that we don't
have lots of things now but now that
we're able to kind of contemplate
putting them into into a package what
are things that would come to you the
things that come to mind are generally
the plans I've seen are two linear and
the world is a nonlinear
place at the one end the chemists are
doing chemistry in the chemical
engineers doing chemical engineering and
the physicists are doing their thing
diverse interacting systems result in
much better outcomes to the point where
about 10 12 years ago when I took a
sabbatical from investing I sent it
spent it became a postdoc at the Santa
Fe Institute in complex systems theory
my kids loved it by the way because I
was sold on my math had to get a math
PhD from Stanford to come to to me for
six months to brush up my math so I
could actually go build complex systems
models I think complexity isn't included
enough and nonlinear effects from comp
come from complex interactions I
mentioned medical studies one of the
causal reasons they are wrong is if I am
a drug company and i'm doing a diabetic
drug right i really don't care about
improving the world i care about getting
my drug approved so what do i do I get a
population that's high likelihood do not
have complexity in it so while clinical
trials so hard because they select
somebody who has high blood sugar but
doesn't have hypertension they don't
have cardiac disease they might not have
thyroid disease turns out they might not
have mental illness turns out depression
and diabetes of comorbidities so they
get very high approval rates because
this person is taking one drug only
theirs and the trial passes in real life
most of the people who have diabetes
taking a drug for depression for cardiac
disease for hypertension and complex
interactions start to happen that's why
most studies are more
likely to be wrong than right which it
just boggles my mind that we don't do
something about this fundamental fact
every piece of medicine with every pill
we take is based on studies that are
more likely to be wrong than right you
just makes me shiver so complex systems
are really important this morning we
were talking about electric car
batteries a little bit and I said do you
realize electric car batteries and
whether they're viable or not are
impacted much more not as much but much
more by weather machine learning and
robotic autonomous drivers and
driverless cars become popular then by
improvements in lithium-ion chemistry I
will challenge anybody to challenge me
on the following fact any improvement in
lithium-ion chemistry which is the
assumption on how batteries will go and
under another assumption of experts I
don't believe almost certainly the
solution will not be lithium ion in my
view but any improvement in chemistry in
lithium ion is likely to be less
consequential to electric cars than
autonomous driverless cars why for the
simple reason if you had an autonomous
car you could get a car to drive 10
times as much per year if you can
amortize that 10 times faster you can't
get a 10x improvement in lithium ion
economics you can get a 10x improvement
in autonomous vehicles driving the car
so you get a hundred thousand miles per
year instead of ten thousand miles per
year per car and acid used that's what i
mean by complex system so i think that's
very important at the other extreme
almost all the efforts I've seen I've
seldom seen computational physics
computational biology computational
material science computational fluid
dynamics used enough so interactions
across disciplines and more fun
science is key to energy than
incremental improvements in what we know
so those are two opposite ends one is
complex systems interactions and the
other is really more fundamental science
very everything in the metal is mostly
inconsequential ver very good advice now
we're sitting here and there's all these
lights and so I don't know that see out
quite so well but I want to turn it over
to questions from the audience and if I
kind of squint it you'll know why so if
you have a question just raise your hand
i do see okay right right there hi so
you don't say also who you are and where
you're sure i'm a senior math major um
Elliot given given your conjecture that
you should challenge the status quo very
often how does that affect how industry
and academia should interact in the
context to entrepreneurship right so if
you're an entrepreneur and you're
interested in working with a professor
or you're a academic and you're
interested in taking something that
you've discovered and bring it into
industry how exactly given that you are
sort of the status quo how does that
change no you know the same polym would
say don't go to college alright his his
book new book aunty fragile is way more
important than most people realize this
some fundamental ideas and they speak
it's called anti fragile for a reason he
argues that we build overly engineered
systems and what we're really doing is
increasing fragility and in error prone
systems you get more robustness more
maturity and it doesn't matter whether
it's in financial systems in the
financial crisis will and he essentially
talked about it happening before it
happened so he's one of the few people I
respect you build robustness into the
systems he would argue that doing is
more important than learning
at least credentialing I'm not quite a
believer in that but I do believe in
mixing learning and doing at the same
time is much more important and it
changes what you learn and what you
retain and how you learn I'll give you
an example in our own field there was a
guy who used to work for me and we have
a rule when young guys join our venture
firm khosla ventures they cannot stay
there too long that means there's no
career path to become an investor by
joining us which is pretty controversial
but he was with us for three years and
then he did his own startup and started
things and he said to me a year later he
said I heard you speak advise
entrepreneurs for three years he said I
interpreted them very differently then I
do now now that I'm an entrepreneur so
the same teaching but you know in
teaching it's not what's the message
that sent that's important it's the
message that you received we assume
message sent is message received but
that's not true mostly learning is worse
than the game of telephone whisper
telephone message received is seldom
like the message sent and the message
received can change based on what you're
doing how you are interacting how much
in real life so I think interaction is
much more important I'll try and keep my
answers shorter but I I think it's
pretty important it gets very relevant
for what we strive to and hopefully can
strive perhaps even further and trying
to make real world problem solving and
learning and doing and making kind of
part of the part of you look in some
departments it's much easier to do in
computer science it's much easier to
hack together a website and and my son's
our sophomore in computer science at
Stanford then
you're much easier my daughter's a
junior in civil engineering it's much
more much harder to be as hands-on right
and interactive so it does depend my
oldest daughter design which is a
mechanical engineering discipline at
Stanford so you have to meet and there
was easy to be hands-on you could study
about materials but when you did design
and then tried material science and need
to know about properties of materials
your view of Port de Belon changed in
material science changed we I think we
got a good sense walking in through the
hull here of other the hands-on I think
in the west bend the art students yes
uh-huh but by the way I being in the cfi
I'm against liberal arts education in
undergraduate I think it's the worst
thing you can do first every engineer
should get enough liberal arts education
but the flip is true I wouldn't consider
anybody educated if they didn't have any
computer science science Technic
engineering education you are not our
view of liberal education is what came
over from England in the 1800s it's
silly to think that a liberal science
major doesn't need to know computer sign
we have this silly language requirement
and high schools and colleges the most
important language is programming not
French if I had to pick between the two
which one would you pick my I was proud
of my daughter's change ferd has a
language requirement sure she decided to
use sign language which is spend the
least time wasting least time wasting
your time learning something that's a
historical anomaly so I think now if you
want to stand study French literature
only time or fine arts or the cello only
time it's important is in a graduate
program right basic education should be
the same for everybody
our society has become so
knowledge-based that we should stop
extending the past you know in the past
we said everybody should get a high
school education and then do what they
think well that benchmark has since
moved to basic education where you
understand how your car works how
engines work as much as how Shakespeare
works in fact I'd venture to say
Shakespeare is not as important and
knowing how your thermostat works which
I find ninety-five percent of people on
the planet still don't know how to
operate a simple thermostat
intelligently on on their wall so the
nature of Education has to change what's
essential nobody should graduate from
CMU without being able to read every
article in The Economist every week you
can't do social science and psychology
till you know statistics otherwise you
get stupid social science which most of
social science is things that are not
validated or rally dateable or provable
so if you don't know statistics don't
tell me you're doing psychology I don't
want to talk to you if you know
statistics then I'm really interested in
what you can tell me about behavioral
science in fact there's no engineer who
should graduate without multiple courses
in human behavior in psychology or
economics really important but based on
real provable repeatable facts sorry
that's a beef of mine whoever's from
Modern Languages we're going to add Java
and C++ s well so so you bring up an
important issue you shouldn't be able to
do language without doing linguistics
absolutely I mean linguistics should be
an essential part of every curriculum
whether you're doing material science or
you're doing music or the Curie of music
should be really an essential to me
those are the essentials of learning how
to learn and think in capabilities
actually I think that you know here are
like our language tech
nology institute which is basically a
department in computer science but it
had its roots in linguistics philosophy
and hillis tree should be essential
linguistic should be essential but not
the easy parts of those hmm right
literature you can do all day long on
your own if you're smart educated person
Jane Austen is not as important as most
of the things the structure of language
the structure of music all really
important so people over interpret the
traditional notion of liberal arts
should be abolished and anybody wasting
250 grand of their parents money to get
a degree like that and then be
unemployable I got into a controversy
recently because there was a guy who did
a Yale program and then tweeted the only
job I can get is bartending and I said
that's courses you took and wasted the
privilege of being able to go to Yale
and spend 250 grand of your parents
money and you forgot the obligation you
had to use a 12 do you know this movie
men in black where you take the little
thing go Bink Bink and you'll forget all
this on any way out the dark when you
you won't remember any of what what we
just what was just discussed um let's
see it was such actors like there's
little i have strong views on every yeah
i think you that was where i left legs
yeah i forgot my question I'm only
kidding I'm Alan rosenblum a physician
researcher former life I was in ICU and
I never treated infectious fever there
it's 5,000 years ago the Chinese have a
symbol for fever blah blah blah Blee
know it clears infection anyway my
question is navigating the minefield of
this yeah by geography navigating the
mine field of entrepreneurship there's a
whole bunch of icebergs and one that
really disturbs me is given I'll give
you two short examples one I learned
over here at the extra electric garage
somewhere around 90 for Toyota had a
electric car the battery the guy who
invented the bed
this is what they told me over there so
I'm quoting them sold it to GE figuring
that GE would mass produce at etc GE
then looked around like any company how
can we make the most money off of this
well they decided to make the most money
off of it by selling it to shale oil you
know it happened shell suit Toyota 470
million for okay that's example1
example2 I'm personally know a group
that invented a beautiful handheld of
what a beautiful handheld flow
cytometers and gets cd4 levels very
important in treating HIV and this thing
you can't have a sheath flow so they use
sound focusing brilliant design bought
so the VCS wanted their money back and
they said okay we're going to sell this
off to and be trogen the scientists this
is in New Mexico well let's keep the
question short let me answer that anyway
invitrogen bought it and killed it and
that was their plan all along so how can
you prevent your best intention and your
great invention from just being bought
and killed yeah so this is a great
question for a forum on innovation a
couple of things one that realities of
life is not every good idea gets into
the market and there's 20 the
fundamental notion of innovation implies
change change implies disruption and
most of existing society benefits from
not changing things not disrupting
things I'm there's always an interest in
keeping things the way they are the oil
companies don't water on biofuels or
electric cars that G doesn't want to
interrupt this gas to combined cycle gas
turbine business so there's most of the
established interest is in not changing
thanks there's again expert opinion that
what you ought to do if you want to
scale something is go to the large
companies I was talking to the
gentlemen in robotics doing the
driverless car at CMU last night briefly
got in late he was willing to meet late
at night and he said you know we're
working with General Motors and I said
oh no almost a guarantee of failure
right then first they have no interest
in disrupting cars if you have a
driverless car you'll need fewer of them
GE won't do that General Electric one
hour General Motors won't do that all
right the other is they have a good
business and everybody there is on a
career path and career paths have
asymmetric benefits if you succeed you
get minor benefit if you fail it's
permanently on your record so it
discourages this notion i talked about
failure big companies don't like to fail
which means they take only incremental
risks no large innovation has come from
big companies did Toyota or General
Motors do the electric car or did Tesla
did NBC new media change or did Google
did walmart do retailing change or
Amazon I could go on and on and on I've
really never seen a big company in a
weight or be able to effectively bring
innovation to market why because they
over planet they think they can predict
the future when all you can do is try
little things fail pivot left pivot
right use every failure to learn adapt
and change and that's not a comfortable
thing in a large company and that's why
all large project spell show innovation
doesn't start from big companies and
they can't scale it at some point you
can get them involved when the risk is
low but while the risk is high no big
company can do it and culturally they
don't have what reward risk-taking and
hence innovation big companies
oxymoron together um so and and the
other reality is you will have failure
because people will want to kill
technologies that's not the first time
it's happened so unfortunate part of
life is real life has some unpleasant
things you know I don't like to see
animal killed but it's just part of life
so I'm sitting this way and I want to
make sure I don't short change over here
so right there is that yeah okay my name
is Daniel I'm from computer science so
you'll be talking a little about being
afraid so I wanted to go a little deeper
into this the nature of fear when you're
trying to go forward with interpret like
to speak up somehow the acoustics are
not set up just to get sound from their
here I get a design from here to there s
message sent not message received this
okay so you would mention fear being
afraid of moving forward different
things so I wanted to go deeper into
this nature of fear and how to actually
attack it and I wanted to go at it at a
specific example so since you're related
to energy well at least it says that
over there and how about let's say
nuclear energy are we too afraid of it
it's supposed to be the most amazing
technology that I personally have seen
in terms of you know being able to
produce that from a very small piece of
materials so what will be your thoughts
on that kind of thing yeah um you know
my favorite saying on fear is this you
know people like to talk about courage
and especially courage of your
convictions I talked about religion and
passion about what you do but the word
courage is meaningless if you're not
afraid there is no courage without fear
you have no fear of something then
doesn't take courage to do it it's an
essential part of risk-taking if
something was low res somebody would
already have done
if something is risky then you have to
have fear and you need courage all I can
say is certain people i incline that way
some people aren't one of the things I
mentioned the god gene earlier i think
the god gene actually minimizes the
perception of risk so you need less
courage to do something by making you a
little bit stupider about the real risks
and i often say if i detect if i knew
all the risks in a start-up before i
started I'd mostly not started all right
and so this sort of blissful ignorance
premature confidence arrogance all these
essential ingredients of innovation and
entrepreneurship as well as sort of
overcoming your fears the best way i've
done it is i start in life not needing
much and i said so i have very little to
lose and a lot to gain because if you
don't have much you don't you can't lose
much in fact when i did my first startup
i said to one of my VC friends i think
this country is great it's a great deal
where if we win we went every lose you
lose because i'm not putting any money
essentially the only thing i had to lose
when i did my first startup was my
student loans there was nothing else I
could learn and so one phrasing it right
and saying what is the risk you're
taking you might risk take a risk at a
technology development and it may fail
but if you view it as failure that's one
way if you r you it at as learning with
somebody else's money that's pretty good
you don't have to spend 250 k of your
parents money spend some venture
capitalists money learning and then if
you sort of say I'm better off in doing
my next thing it becomes much
easier to take the risk very good let me
see right there if somebody can see
where I'm pointing to see hands I don't
see people but there's the microphone
yeah okay hi my name is Matt I'm a first
year MBA student my question is
entrepreneur's spend so much of their
time championing their ideas and
convincing the world that they have the
next big thing I was curious but before
it is I was curious if you could maybe
share your story of Sun Microsystems of
that moment where you knew this was
going to be the next big thing I like to
say that the huge difference and
startups often confuse this between
strategy and tactics being obstinate
about your vision is important you're
going to go change the world and that
son we knew we wanted distributed
computing to happen and everybody told
me why don't you become a graphics
terminal on deck back says deck has
disappeared but that was the dominant
computing environment deck an IBM and
building graphics terminals for them
that was the incremental approach right
but we were very very clear we want to
do distributed computing and we were i
would say foolishly visionary first we
made networking Ethernet standard on
every sun we ever ship nobody had ever
done that in computing but right but his
his the scary part we wasted a lot of
money every son shipped early on had DES
encryption because I imagined the
security world as being important to
networked in distributed computing it
was a bad idea because the world wasn't
ready for security so as though my
strategic vision of needing DES
encryption and every node was actually
exactly right in 1982 tactically
implementing it
wasn't so it's important to be obstinate
about your vision and strategy but you
have to be really flexible about your
tactics and not get stuck up usually
people who are visionary will not
compromise that vision to be tactically
effective and the way to think about
data is you can't get to your vision in
one step you need 20 steps along the way
and at each of these steps you garner
some resources nice people believe you
so you can do the next incremental thing
so you pretend to do little things and
sometimes of course things like we had a
huge fight and somebody eventually
convinced me to take networking out of
the Sun and put what would then call me
t100 rs-232 ports so it could be used a
time-sharing machine that was that
tactical compromise of my vision but it
got us enough revenue to get the next
funding to do the next thing and so
being very very flexible on tactics but
being obstinate about your vision is an
important part and that happened many
many times its Sun and that's why I say
you discover your business plan you
don't make it but your vision you should
be generally something you're passionate
about happening and you should be
flexible about your vision a little bit
but but generally if you're too flexible
with your vision you become to
opportunistic and give up on the larger
picture great oh yes right here yeah go
ahead I think the microphones coming to
you my name is harsh monthly can you
hear me yes and I've just taken the leap
from the corporate world to being a
student again as an adjunct faculty my
question has to do with coal energy and
India and China you made a very
compelling presented a very compelling
and stimulating point of view on trying
to invent your own future
India and China are mushrooming or the
use of coal and the result in pollution
is mushrooming what approach would you
take if you had that problem well I'll
tell you what we attempting turns out
when your economy is growing at ten
percent or six percent or eight percent
a year its infrastructure is generally
growing fat needs to grow faster that
means roads buildings construction so I
personally taken the approach and i'm
often wrong so let me start there is to
say all the expert opinion about taking
co2 separating it and sequestering it is
complete baloney it is exactly the wrong
thing to do but if I can use the carbon
dioxide effectively carbon dioxide is
bad calcium carbonate which is probably
this stone here is one form of carbonate
is good so with the magic of
electrochemistry if you can turn co2
into co 3 carbonate ions then you
actually have really valuable products
we just built a new building fifteen
percent of the cement and our floors and
walkways is all carbon captured as
cement so that's an example that
requires hard innovation in
electrochemistry to make the co 2 2 co 3
conversion cheap and that generally
means lowest energetic cost of producing
a no h ion i won't go too much into the
detail at the other end it's taking
carbonates and doing finding nano
structures that increase their value
whether it says granite or marble or
cement or something else so that when
you ask fundamental questions as opposed
to read expert opinion and believe it
you come up with very different answers
I find that's an example Cole would then
become economic
because you'd be co-producing cement in
those economy is needed I'm looking at
my handler who is telling me for reasons
I will explain that in a second that we
we must wrap up here in just one more
question I believe so i have a
concluding item after this question but
let me pick somebody for the last for
the last question that hand right
there's been the most vociferous hey my
name is magan i'm a chemical engineering
major at carnegie mellon yeah i'll speak
up back up oh I'm a chemical engineering
major that was it ah and so you talked a
lot about yeah not being certain and not
and knowing that we don't know that much
what do you think in general about
having the control about future events
and is that even the notion that's like
desirable having the control about what
happens yeah so the question i'll repeat
as I understood it is you have to
control future events what do I think
about it obviously that's true at many
many levels the fundamental thing I
would say is we focus too much on
providing reducing failure which means
increasing control and predictability
there's another way to make failure more
acceptable and that's to reduce the
consequences of a failure so let me give
you an example if I take a computer
system and flip a chip or cut a wire it
normally fail if I cut my finger my body
keeps going it's a resilient error-prone
system it's tolerant to errors and
mistakes and failures by and large I
think because of our engineering mindset
we've done more of prevent failure stuff
and less of reduce the consequences of
failure so we can tolerate more failure
I think at the social level especially
at complex systems I think we should
engineer
for more failure but make it smaller
that's what I think to the extent
control becomes in the electrical
engineering world a software problem and
all software is free essentially and
mostly computing is free putting more
power into control is a good thing let
me end by saying one generalized comment
it relates to your question but in a
much more generalized way the world
economy is becoming more about ideas the
capitalist system was invented when
labor was the principal way earning
happened if there's an economist that we
have it they'll be happy to hear this
especially liberal economists if you got
paid for your labor you only had eight
thousand hours of labor if you worked a
hundred percent of the time in a year
unfortunately or fortunately I actually
consider it's fortunate the economy has
moved to one driven by ideas and so
labor is no longer an important
component of the economy ideas are
that's why innovation becomes important
that's why entrepreneurship becomes
important that's why I believe the power
of ideas fueled by entrepreneurial
energy is the single most important
force in the world for good and
intellectual horsepower learning real
learning become really really important
in the fate of the planet and you get
phenomena like a mark zuckerberg can
make 25 billion dollars or whatever he's
made org larry page because multiplying
ideas is easy
multiplying a car physically a hundred
times costs a hundred times as much
maybe fifty times as much because of
scale economics and all that but
multiplying an idea doesn't take extra
costs and so ideas become
disproportionately powerful tools and
disport portion utley more valuable so
as long as the economy moves to the
power of ideas driven by innovation we
will see more asymmetry in economics the
disparity what's called the Gini
coefficient in economics between the
rich and the poor will keep going up the
poor won't be the people with the
resources will be people with ideas so
social mobility will hopefully increase
but it is a fundamental change in the
structure of global economics and
capitalism that we haven't included in
the theory of economics but innovation
is the principal reason and the power of
ideas intellectual ideas is what's
driving this thanks thank you very much
if that was really nice thank you thank
you I'd like to thank our guest he has
an extraordinarily busy schedule is
going to be meeting with President
Suresh in Philadelphia before a few a
couple more hours and then I know you
have speaking come set of commitments in
New York City but we are speaking
engagement in Philadelphia two o'clock
so we are doubly grading at new york
city's i apologize i have a run we are
we're slowly let me just say anybody who
has communicate i know people who have
questions for me feel free to email me
at VK at khosla ventures com I'll be
impolite and run and remember being
impolite is important if if people are
interested in impolite I gave a talk to
a high school kids a lot of Indian kids
and Chinese kids in this high school and
I gave my talk about why they should not
listen to their teachers why they should
throw food color outside the lines it's
on our website I actually think it
captures some really important ideas
about behavior and what is acceptable
and what you should do to challenge
what's acceptable and let me say that
for all of you who are liberal arts
majors please we're gathering in the
corner after this talk for the therapy
sessions that will be required thank you
very much thanks a lot that's great
thank you